we start with some breaking news out of
austria chancellor alexander
schallenbach has announced a full
nationwide lockdown starting monday and
it will become the first european
country to make covid19 vaccines
mandatory starting february only
two-thirds of the country's population
is fully vaccinated one of the lowest
rates on the continent austria is
currently in the grip of a severe fourth
wave of the pandemic
let's get the very latest on the story
we have our correspondent fanny fachar
standing by in vienna hi funny so a
lockdown and mandatory vaccination
starting in february tell us more about
these measures that have been decided
and why we're seeing them now
chances schollenberg announced what two
state governors were actually asking for
already yesterday that's a nationwide
lockdown they said the two state
governors of salzburg and uber australia
which are heavily
affected compared to other states they
said they must be a locked and if there
isn't they're going to have regional
lockdown starting on monday so now
chancellor schoenberg with that mounting
pressure actually on his shoulders made
the decision a very unfavorable decision
to make he actually said that it hurts
to make this decision after all
christmas is around the corner and
people here who are hoping for good
business are now insecure what's going
to happen because practically what's
going to happen is what happened already
three times before this is the fourth
lockdown during this almost two-year
pandemic and that means that shops will
be closed and people can only leave
their homes if they need to get
essentials go to the pharmacy or go to
work that's the situation right now and
on top of that what is really raising
eyebrows among those who don't want to
get vaccinated is the mandatory
vaccination that's supposed to come into
force starting next year february 1st
i know these measures have just been
announced but how much support do you
think there really is in austria for
these
the situation here in austria just like
in many other countries where people
politicians but health experts and just
people on the ground ordinary citizens
are debating is quite similar people are
split over these measures you will have
people say
why now why not already three weeks ago
have a lockdown before in fact all these
hospitals are on the brink of almost of
a collapse why now why not even sooner
but you will also have people who will
actually go to the streets take to the
streets tomorrow here in vienna who say
this is way too much this is a way of
actually getting involved in your
personal choice whether you want to get
vaccinated and a lockdown is not the way
forward you will have different
statements also on a political level and
that's what's really difficult here as
long as you do not have a united voice
both on a social level and on a
political level the question really is
is this a lockdown before another
lockdown another lockdown experts say
the only way forward is full vaccination
for everyone here in austria
dw's funny fachar reporting they're from
vienna where austria has announced it's
opposing another full nationwide
lockdown starting on monday thank you
very much funny
germany is also experiencing a severe
fourth wave of the pandemic lawmakers
here have approved a new package of
measures to contain the spread of covet
19. the number of new cases has jumped
by more than 60 percent in just two
weeks the rules will impact many areas
of daily life including at the workplace
a new daily routine at this siemens
factory
workers cue to show their vaccine
certificates are covet 19 test results
employees who don't comply will be
suspended without pay you know new
measures that will soon be imposed
across germany
after parliament approved a law to
counter rampant coronavirus infection
rates it was submitted by the three
parties likely to form germany's next
government
outgoing chancellor angela merkel had
been urging action at a meeting with
state premiers
with the current momentum we're running
into a very difficult situation
especially for people who work in
hospitals and particularly in intensive
care
we have always said that we don't want
to overburden our health system
we know that we can't prevent that
across the board right now but
fortunately we still have the capacity
to help in many places
but it is high time to act
other absolutely in the new covet 19 law
include a nationwide rule allowing
access to public transport only to those
who have been tested vaccinated or
recently recovered from the virus
with infection rates soaring more people
here want to see tougher measures
i think too little is being done i also
think the city hesitated for too long to
impose any restrictions
a general vaccine mandate more tests and
testing those who have been vaccinated
as well then things will get better
i think we have to introduce compulsory
vaccinations now
a general vaccine mandate isn't part of
the new law but a prominent health
expert believes the measures will make a
difference
restrictions that we decided today will
work if they are used
appropriately and if we really
use them to the fullest extent
the law has also been approved by the
second chamber representing the federal
states
the rules will now come to force as
early as next week
this was the first test for the new
constellation of federal and state
leaders
and one they couldn't afford to fail
well the new law includes several
measures let's take a closer look at
those now
anyone going to work or using public
transport needs to be vaccinated have
recently recovered from an infection or
they have to show a negative covid19
test here in germany that's known as the
3g rule
once a specific hospitalization rate is
reached those who are not vaccinated or
recovered will not be allowed to enter
bars restaurants large events that is
the so-called 2g rule and the measure
known as 2g plus that means those who
are vaccinated and recovered they will
still have to show a negative test
result to enter recreational venues now
there will also be a vaccine mandate for
certain professions like healthcare
workers or those who work in care homes
given that millions of germans reject
the vaccine this will likely be the most
controversial measure
let's bring in our correspondent nina
hasa who's following the latest on this
story for us hi nina good to see you so
we're talking about tighter covert
restrictions plans to boost the vaccine
uptake but we are in the middle of this
record-breaking fourth wave of the
pandemic so will this work
well angela merkel called it extremely
dramatic the current situation that
we're in uh so let me look at the
the fact that they're trying to boost
the vaccine uptake this morning the
outgoing health minister in spain held a
press conference like every friday again
now where he said in berlin that he's
noticing that people are beginning to
see the dramatic extent of the current
situation and he mentioned explicitly
the fact that gps and local doctors have
now ordered significantly more vaccine
doses than they did two weeks ago so
that means that people are approaching
their gps to get vaccinated for the
first time or even for the third time
for those booster vaccinations and the
hope is of course that more reluctant
people will get vaccinated now or else
they will risk losing pay at work for
example but there are still millions of
people who don't believe the science
that vaccines actually work and
regarding your first question will the
restrictions work well they will make
life a lot more difficult for
unvaccinated people but the plans are
coming very late and there are many
regions here now where there are no free
intensive care unit beds anymore and
those beds are occupied by mostly
unvaccinated covert patients and so the
health minister warned that germany
really is preparing for the collapse of
its health system let's take a listen
we are getting to a point now where we
will have to transfer covet patients not
just within the same region but to other
regions within germany
and quite possibly even abroad to
neighboring countries
the federal government and the states
are in close contact about that
sunina we see lawmakers making these
dramatic appeals to people is there
support for these measures across the
country
the debate in parliament on thursday was
intense and fractures they debated that
new law that is going to come into
effect now angela merkel's party the cdu
was against the passing of that law but
you wouldn't be wrong to think that
there was a certain degree of party
power play at work there in that debate
and in any case the conservatives then
didn't block the law today in the
bundesliga which is of course the second
chamber where the regions sit together
so the new restrictions are coming into
effect and as far as the general public
support for those restrictions is
concerned there is a lot of support
because there is a sense that
politicians essentially had taken their
eyes off the ball to a certain degree
over the summer people were busy with
the election campaign etc and that's
something that the president of the
bundestag actually accused the outgoing
government of
that they were being sluggish because of
the federal election so the majority of
germans now just want everybody to pull
together and get vaccinated so that this
fourth uh wave can actually be broken
dws nina hasa reporting for us good to
talk to you
well for more let's bring in dr uber
janssen he's the secretary general of
the german society for intense internal
intensive care and emergency medicines
dr janssen thanks for joining us on dw
the the numbers in germany are simply
soaring how worried are you
yeah
yeah
rebecca the numbers are absolutely
worrying almost
65 000 new infections yesterday and
almost 58 000 new infections today
the seven day incidence has peaked out
at
340 and as you know
we will see patients with a severe
course in the intensive care unit much
later with a delay of up to 15 days
counted from now on and currently around
0.8
of infected people will have to be
treated
further in an intensive care unit during
the course of the infection and if you
see at the numbers fifty thousand sixty
thousand you can count how many people
will reach the intensity care unit in
seven to ten to twelve days and this is
much too much
to handle um
at this situation so we're likely to see
then a point where germany really the
health care system reaches the overload
point and and
yeah could you explain a little bit
about when that might happen
yes at the moment we have the situation
that in the south of germany in bavaria
saxonia and martin ruttenberg and other
areas the
hospitals and even the intensive care
units have such a high pressure
such a high load that in some regions
there are
zero free intensive care units bad so we
have to stop the regular operations the
regular operation has to be stopped and
the politicians didn't say anything
yesterday to this very critical and up
point of utmost importance so you see if
you postpone um operation which can be
postponed without uh
do harm to the patient you will set free
additional healthcare work is from the
operation theatre and the anaesthesia
unit to help and to support uh the
people on the intensive care units and
you will set free beds to treat the
patient so these measures has to be
taken uh very very quickly and the last
year in march uh the chancellor and the
minister presidents they did these
measures and now we don't hear anything
about this
well the politicians obviously think
that these new measures are enough from
a medical perspective are these measures
enough to get things under control here
yes overall these measures may have an
effect but unfortunately they come far
too late the pandemic hit germany with
full force in southern germany as i said
and other
regions we have exorbitantly high
numbers of infections due to low
vaccination rates and intensive care
medicine is at the limit of its capacity
therefore in addition to these measures
we have to intensify the vaccinations as
much as possible but above all the
booster vaccinations and unfortunately
the vaccination centers were closed even
though the development was foreseeable
now we are chasing after things
all right dr uber janssen with the
german society for internal intensive
care and emergency medicine thanks very
much for your time
thank you